CS 2's last massive update made a lot of
improvements to some issues players were
having with how the game felt
mechanically which is fantastic but
looming behind every new update that
valve rolls out is the expectation that
they'll finally do something about cs2s
cheating problem so we sat down with one
of the people responsible for creating
valerant Vanguard anti-che system to
find out how this issue can be solved
once and for all this is a whole
perception battle that you have to on
the ancient side of things you know
having good detections and getting
cheaters out matters uh but also making
sure that that's visible to the
community matters too and if it looks
like you're not taking action then
you're actually encouraging cheating in
a lot of ways on your
platform first off thanks to Rog for
sponsoring this video here's Demitri to
tell you more about their Black Friday
Friday sale all right first things first
if you are in the market for a killer
gaming monitor boy do I have some good
news for you Gamers this year Rog are
having an exclusive 15% off Black Friday
sale on their Swift OLED pg27 aqm
monitor only on Amazon we actually just
partnered with Rog for a cracked where
Colton and I built a god tier rig just
to test out rog's new 540 HZ monitor
that said all of rog's gaming displays
are top here and the pg27 is no
exception it's the brightest OLED gaming
monitor on the market boasting colors
and contrast that you need to see to
believe the pg27 also offers 1440p
resolution and a 240 HZ refresh rate
which is pretty much the perfect
combination for any real capital G gamer
so head over to Amazon if you're in need
of a stellar upgrade that won't break
the bank now back to the video okay so
we all know that cheating in CS2 right
now is really bad so much so so that it
could be one of the major reasons the
game is seeing a player count drop
n what makes you say
that what makes you say
that now it's not like valve isn't aware
of this issue and I would love to
believe that they're dedicating like 90%
of their brain power to solving this
issue but it's been almost 2 months
since the game released and over six
since it was first teased along with all
the data mining of any mention of an
improved anti-che so the question is
what the hell happened along the road
and when can we actually expect an
update well before we can even try to
answer that we need to go back two years
ago and introduce our new friend Nena
mulus Mich or Nei for short you see back
in 2021 before CS2 was even confirmed to
be real csgo's cheating problem was argu
just as bad as it is now back then there
were almost non-stop complaints about
the underperformance of back and it got
to the point where a Val programmer John
McDonald even faced some persecution but
it was at that moment that sparked Nei
to publicly reach out on Twitter to
offer his assistance but what makes Nei
such an authority on the subject that he
could solve csgo's biggest problem well
after working for the US government
Department of Defense as a software
engineer with a top secret clearance Nei
went out to work for blizzard developing
anti-che before he was brought on by
Riot to do the exact same thing until he
ultimately helped develop valerent
Vanguard system an antiche that is
arguably one of the best in the business
right now so yeah I would say that Nei
knows what the he's talking about but
John McDonald or Val for that matter
never responded and Nei went on to build
his own company and his own powerful
anti-che that was eventually acquired by
roblocks just last year so we reached
out to Nei to figure out where
everything went wrong and first first
and foremost his response came from a
place of sympathy as a player you I want
Val to be successful I want Conor strike
to be successful that's the game I grew
up playing right and it doesn't it does
feel like a little disappointing that
they're not taking as serious as they
can because you know valve is a very
successful company they have the
resources and the money to throw serious
uh skin into this effort and make a big
dent for cheating it's just that I don't
know if it's a priority for them that's
the big thing like I I don't see it
being prioritized as much as some of
their other athletes and that's just the
nature of the business what are those
other priorities well Nei suggests it
could be things like the steam deck
steam itself and other money-making
products now nemi admits it's not like
valve is doing nothing the improvements
they've already made to vac things like
machine learning and server side
detection is very impressive and
important but he also goes on to say
that that's only half the battle Nei
says to properly deal with cheating you
need a combination of three things
detection prevention and deterrence the
anti-che itself that actually detects
the hackers when they pop up
anti-tampering software that makes it as
hard to make cheats as possible and then
Banning people who try either and at the
heart of all of this is that anti-tamper
software as Nei explained to us the
number one goal should be making
cheating as inaccessible and expensive
as possible you kind of restrict that
just like the top tier Talent who really
just doing it for business and when you
only have a few cheat sellers it makes
it way easier for the company to
prioritize them whether that means like
go after them with legal action or uh
you know uh Target them for detection
because when there's only one or two
cheats for your game it's easy to you
know get a copy of that cheat reverse
engineer it and make detections for it
but when you have thousands of cheats
for your game well what do you
prioritize that gets very complicated
and Nei has proofed that this approach
to anti-che actually works I mean
anecdotally valerant feels like a pretty
cheat-free experience for the average
player which is a direct result of
cheating being very costly and Annoying
It's not like valerin doesn't have any
cheaters it's just been reduced to a
small group of people that are willing
to dedicate the effort for more concrete
evidence Nei claims that Roblox SAW a
97% decrease in cheaters on Windows when
they got rid of the old anti-che system
97% is a big number so how does valve
replicate this well as Nei said before
first things first this needs to become
the main priority for valve and
improving the anti-tamper side of things
is going to do a lot in fighting this
battle and although it isn't 100%
necessary valve can greatly increase
their odds at winning this battle if
they decide to go a certain route one
that CS players have been actually
asking for for quite some time a kernel
driver similar to valerent Vanguard a
kernel program essentially gives better
access to anti-che to view the processes
going on on one's computer to better
detect things like cheating or spoofing
now that does seem a bit scary providing
basically unfettered access to a company
like that but as Nei explained it really
comes down to whether or not you trust
the company to install their software on
your computer or not and if you don't
trust them you probably shouldn't be
playing their game in the first place so
is that just it then valve just needs to
make this a bigger priority focus on
preventative measures and maybe toss in
some good old kernel axis to speed
things up well yeah sort of but as Nei
made it clear through our conversation
it's easier said than done what Nei has
committed basically his entire life to
and what people working on vac do every
day is no small mountain to climb and in
the case of CS2 it isn't US versus valve
it's valve and US versus the cheaters
listen none of us actually know how much
time and effort is being put into back
right now we could see an update next
week it could be a year from now but the
point I made the other week and what Nei
said today stands true saying nothing is
helping no one right now people are
leaving the game because they don't know
what the is going on or what the future
holds and cheaters are only emboldened
because they think they have nothing to
worry about I want to know how much
money this character has made like just
globally like from materials sold to
make cosplays for it to skins in
fortnite of this character to the skins
that maybe they've sold in the street
fighter games for it probably a lot and
we have now contributed to it by buying
whatever this figurine is supposed to be